sabemos que el carbono 12 es el isótopo
más común en la tierra el 98 puntos 89
por ciento del carbono en la tierra es
carbono 12 y sabemos que por definición
su masa es exactamente de 12 unidades de
masa atómica pero ese no es el único
isótopo de carbono en la tierra existen
otros isótopos el siguiente más común es
el carbono 13 1.11 por ciento del
carbono en la tierra es carbono 13 y
experimentalmente podemos saber que su
masa es de 13.00 34 unidades de masa
atómica entonces estos números que
tenemos aquí solo como un repaso estos
números corresponden a la masa atómica
masa atómica entonces lo que haremos en
este vídeo es pensar en cómo lograron
calcular el peso atómico que nos dan en
la tabla periódica aquí tenemos el peso
atómico
peso atómico
y de dónde viene bueno en el vídeo sobre
peso atómico y masa atómica vimos que el
peso atómico es el peso promedio de las
masas atómicas de varios tipos de ese
elemento
entonces para encontrar este valor
aproximado de 12.01 sacaremos el
promedio de estas dos cosas y eso lo
haremos tomando en cuenta que tan común
es el isótopo entonces lo que haremos es
que tomamos 98 puntos 89 % y lo vamos a
multiplicar por 12 y vamos a reescribir
este porcentaje como décima entonces
tenemos 0.9 88 9 por 12 y a eso le vamos
a sumar 1.11 por ciento por 13.00 34
entonces si escribimos esto como decimal
tenemos 0.0 111 esto es 1.11 por ciento
y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por 13.000
puntos 34
unidades de masa atómica y esto cuánto
nos da bueno usemos la calculadora
tenemos 0.9 88 9 por 12 eso es igual a
11.8 6 6 8 y a esto le vamos a sumar
0.01 11 x 13.00 34 así es como obtenemos
este número atómico ahí lo tiene así es
como se calcula el peso atómico de un
elemento entonces vamos a escribir que
esto es aproximadamente
12.01 es el peso promedio de las masas
atómicas ahora otra cosa que tal vez se
pregunten es cuál es la diferencia entre
el carbono 12 y el carbono 13 bueno el
carbono 12 que tenemos aquí tiene 6
protones 6 protones es lo que hace que
este elemento sea carbono entonces estos
tienen 6 protones y la
diferencia está en los neutrones este
tiene 6 neutrones 6 neutrones y este
tiene un neutrón más es decir que tiene
7 neutrones entonces al analizar la
diferencia en las masas atómicas
observen que la diferencia es de más
1.000 34 unidades de masa atómica y a
partir de esto pueden decir si agregamos
un neutrón más un neutrón eso es
aproximadamente igual a una unidad de
masa atómica no exactamente pero en
términos aproximados podemos verlo muy
cercano a una unidad de masa atómica y
lo mismo ocurre con los protones espero
que ahora ya conozcan cuál es la
diferencia entre la masa atómica que es
la masa y el peso atómico que es un peso
promedio de los diferentes isótopos que
existen de ese elemento en la tierra
espero que ya sepan cómo se calcula y
que sepan cuál es la masa aprox
de un neutro